all right it's time for this week's sin
city chronicles a weekly look back at
vegas history and happenings
and we start off with a happy birthday
to the t-mobile arena
italy's fireworks here for the
celebration that's the home of our vegas
golden knights
it opened on april 6 2016.
the opening night had performances from
the killers
blue man group and wayne newton plus a
couple of surprises
dan reynolds of imagine dragons joined
brandon flowers
for the first time ever on stage the
2021 major league baseball season is
underway
and on april 10th 1983 baseball arrived
in las vegas
the las vegas stars debuted in front of
ten thousand people at cashman field
the aaa baseball team who is an
affiliate of the san diego padres
defeated the salt lake city gauls 11-8
the stars eventually became the 51s and
are now known as the
las vegas aviators
[Music]
nxs was one of the biggest bands of the
80s and 90s here they are performing
at a sold out wembley stadium on april
5th 1991
and they had their first vegas concert
at valleys three years later
on april 5th 1994 uh actually started
april 5th 1994 they sold out to thomas
and mack
so april 5th 1970 howard hughes passed
away at the age of
70. hughes was one of the biggest
figures in las vegas history
among the hotels he owned included the
desert inn
the sands the frontier and the landmark
now back in 1967
hughes purchased channel 8 and his
greenhouse which we see right there
still stands in our back parking lot and
we're going to end with a happy
birthday las vegas resident zach baggins
who's the host of ghost adventures
and owner of the haunted museum
celebrates a birthday
this week happy birthday zach and that's
your sin city chronicles for the first
week of april
las vegas now we'll be right back